hi there welcome back you are watching
sky news let's bring you some breaking
news now regarding the 12 year old boy
archie batterspin if you're a regular
viewer of sky news you'll know that
we've been following the progress of
this story after his parents have been
in a fight with doctors who want to turn
off the life support machine for archie
after he suffered a catastrophic
accident at his home in april the 7th of
this year well we're just hearing now in
the last few minutes from the court of
appeal that doctors can lawfully stop
providing life support treatment to
twelve-year-old archie battesby as you
can see pictures there between archie
and his mum
archie has been in a comatose state
after as i mentioned suffering a
catastrophic brain injury some three
months ago well appeal judges have made
the decision they made the decision on
friday we understand but have just
announced that decision sir andrew
mcfarland the president of the family
division of the high court also lady
justice king and lord justice peter
jackson delivering that ruling and
deciding that doctors can lawfully stop
providing life support and treatment to
archie battersby it's been a long
journey for the family of archie his
parents holly dance and paul battersby
of south end and essex have been very
vocal uh doing an awful lot of press
conferences as you can imagine they've
mounted an appeal after a high court
judge ruled that doctors could lawfully
stop treatment they then took their
fight to
the
high court and now to the appeal court
but the appeal court siding with doctors
opinions doctors who are treating archie
at the royal london hospital in white
chapel in east london think that he is
brain stem dead and they also say
continued life support treatment is not
in his best interests his parents though
disagree we shall try and bring you a
little bit more information on that
maybe we will hear from archie's parents
as well at some point today outside the
court for pill and if we do so we'll
bring that for you
as soon as we see them